we have been hunting Pokemon to the past
couple of days
matt has been gone for several hours we
actually quite concerned about him so
we're going to drop off sunscreen and
his power charger to him right now
said he's on somewhere near he said he's
got a dog so you want to find a wild
nadeshot Pokemon go to the mcdonald
carrying on bastard how important are
these items seats oh he's getting in
it's been a long time since I've seen
you guys we were just leaving you here
oh dude I've been you come in with us
yeah I'm going so I need to get to the
water scientific Gyarados here oh that
can't put weight where we well we can
just you can just begin to drop you up
where we're going we're going to the spa
today having a spa day I'm so sore from
catching pokémon I walk they wanted me
to come guess what I'm committed to
catching the pokey yeah cool yeah guys
are gonna you guys gonna lose your mind
when you see what I got
okay
pheromone fountain this is right here
spotted by oh great spa day that's the
very childhood street of Matt's across
the way and he said he's really
miserable but like I'm not sure we
should feel bad for him because he's
voluntarily putting himself out in the
elements of heat and starvation
how's your call team on hunting well I
think burn yeah server is having a lot
of issues so kind of 9 because I walked
all these a deer and back here you are
one two for cheesecake fit Matt order
for for himself
yep Matt come on we need to go let's go
but bring it with you
sorry I don't play that one it's called
like something bill would it make man
trainer song but it's come on yeah what
else a turn okay I couldn't because
there were cars coming in the time it
you guys tell me the turn that were no
bars
that's it
wow that's a lot you should light those
up right now
line it up okay motor Lord to finally
get rid of
here's problem I don't have any
measurements no measurements we don't
need them this is how you play pokemon
go safely while you're driving
you
we're something too how do we get to it
we've arrived
I just need to get an interior decorator
because I'm not cut out for this I don't
know what I want
well done time to go oh we're done
there's nothing here hey bad idea I need
a drink on board I thought that was like
one of the bigger cb2 stores if the one
in Santa Monica I had like three levels
it's so much stuff but they didn't have
any green sugar hot chocolate if I could
have time this is not even five minutes
from the time it took us longer to go up
the elevator
I'm sorry Matt I'll get your pizza well
keeping your hands ahead inside
we're gonna go get the shot Matt staying
in the car because you you still mad I
feel that we've been making him run
errands all day
poor boy wait wait he made us one
pokemons errands yesterday
oh that's why I'm swimming why it was
another shot so exciting such a good
show guys haven't checked it out make
sure you go check it out it's on Joey's
channel if you guys having YouTube red
unfortunately YouTube red I think it's
only available in the US right now so
hopefully soon they will launch that for
everybody because it's such a good show
and I'm so proud of Joey I had so much
fun shooting it and Matt's also in the
show but he's in the car ah so good so
fun I hope you guys enjoyed if you have
watched it no spoilers in the comments
no spoilers okay kind of make it up this
hill gotta get in that pizza
guys the longer we wait the harder it's
gonna get and the more Pokemon that are
going to get away good morning it's
really early we're going on hunting
today I need a coffee we're taking the
dog it's going to be a struggle but it's
going to be a real good one we're on our
way to the pier to hunt some pokemon mat
businesses where all the water pokemon
are so it would make sense because the
pier is on the water so that's all right
so you want to get a copy post up Allah
I'll drop a lure on one of these that
isn't already take it
yeah the enemy good boy my good boy I
don't want to hunt poking about anymore
but Matt and Jenna keep wanting to hunt
I want to and then I don't
haider oh my goodness I've been trying
to get them to leave and then I went
into the school year the dog Oh human
not run home me and the dog in the car I
told Jen I was like me and Matt will be
in the car there he is
he's real quick you get him yeah Onix
are still close to got out of the car
and they're like we started running
Maddie's always my go-to I don't
remember where I left off in this vlog
but I thought I should probably end it
so see you guys soon I'm heading off to
New York so Jenna's gonna be babysitting
Maddie Matt forgot is the day I'll see
you guys soon I can't wait to go collect
pokemons in New York it's great though
this is tropical Twilight this is the
Savannah sunset but for us